hi this week I want to talk about the
final stage of finishing up a large
project that you've been working on so
in my case that's the PHD so I only have
six months left and I kind of want to
take you guys along in this journey of
finishing up my PhD so all the tips that
I learn along the way and new techniques
I kind of want to give them to you such
that if you're in a process of finishing
up a thesis for a PhD a master or a
bachelor's I think this could really
benefit you so let's get straight into
it so first of all I want to focus on
some personal tips that I've kind of
learned over the last couple of weeks
and the first one that really helped me
get back on track is to have a minimal
viable goal that you work on every day
so for me that's to write up 500 Words
which is about one page I would say and
I noticed that this really helped me get
back on track because if I put a really
large goal like for example finish five
pages in one day I noticed that a lot of
days I don't tend to work as well and I
tend to put off working on on these
things whereas if you have a tiny goal
that you finish every day you kind of
keep the momentum over a couple of days
which will help in the end in finishing
your thesis and I usually put them in a
daily um word tracker in notion so I put
it here and I'm making a notion page
also for the word tracker and in general
for PhD things that I've been using over
the last couple of years so if you want
that I will put it down below in the
link to my newsletter at a certain point
so one other thing I kind of noticed is
to avoid taking full days off in the
weekend although I do usually recommend
this for PhD students that are at the
beginning or Master students to have a
couple of days off in the month that you
fully take off but I think now I kind of
noticed that I like to keep the momentum
so if every day I just do a little bit
in the morning so still write 500 words
in the weekend I noticed that I keep the
momentum on Monday whereas if I take the
complete day off I kind of forget the
threat I was working on so try to
experiment with that and see what works
for you another crucial thing that I
learned and this was really from my
professor is to let go of some of the
projects you're working on so right now
we're finishing up the fourth project
and then we're probably going to write a
little commentary for the final chapter
of the thesis but of course there are
many other side projects that my
professor and I are still working on and
I would love to keep continuing working
on them and right now I feel really the
intense need to procrastinate on these
projects but doing this will really
block your way of finishing your thesis
because in the end you'll be working on
these side projects and you won't be
writing up all the work you have done so
I put all the side projects I had in a
little foul in notion such that if I
ever want to get back to them after I've
written up the Theses and they're still
a couple of months maybe in my PhD then
I can get back to them but right now I'm
trying to put it off and not work on
them anymore then I want to dive a
little bit into the planning strategy so
we had this course on the art of
finishing up your PhD for the planning
strategy what we really learned is to
work work backwards from your final end
submission date so for me my final
submission date will be the 1st of
September probably because that's when
my contract finishes but we're aiming to
submit it before summer because I
already know that the calendars of my
supervisors will be really full during
summer so they probably won't have time
to look at it during summer so try to
establish when you have to finish your
project or your thesis and work
backwards from there once you have your
final end goal think of the couple of
months so in my case like four or five
months and make a visual outline of all
the projects and all the side things
that you still have to finish within
those last months and then what I would
do is to make a list and categorize them
into must do could do and don't really
have to do and really try to remove the
don't really have to do and could do
these kind of side commitments can take
a lot of time and in the last 6 months
you really want to focus on writing as
much as possible so for example try to
remove some of the presentations you're
giving or maybe if you are taking on a
new teaching commitment try to remove
all of this and then what we did is we
created this visual overview of all the
projects in this 3 month timeline and I
kind of tried to visualize when I would
approximately finish all the subs tasks
that need to be finished for the PHD so
now you have your 3 month schedule and
you kind of have the daily things you
want to do but I would also try to think
about how your ideal week looks like so
we work on this tip during the course
and I personally really like it so you
kind of have a blank space of your week
then you first fill in all the
commitments that you definitely have to
attend so for example for me these are
the lab meetings I have to give some
presentations that I cannot remove and
some teaching commitments so you fill
those in first then what I would do is
to block out your rest days so I
definitely would pick out an afternoon
or a few evenings that you definitely
don't do anything or stressful or that
takes a lot of time because as at least
as a PhD student for me I tend to forget
planning these days so that's the second
thing that I would do and then
afterwards I would fill in everything
that I need to to get to these 3 months
so for example I would need to write 500
Words every day to finish on time maybe
make a figure every day and for example
have some coding time in the afternoon
so I fill those in as well and then also
all your side commitment so for me
that's YouTube to finish YouTube things
on time I'm also working for a couple of
outreaching in an Elance so I also put
those in and then kind of see what your
week looks like and if you have to scrap
some things and I think by looking at
this ideal week you can really see if
what you have planned is actually
feasible cuz a lot of times it's not
really feasible and we're not super
aware of this so yeah these are the
couple of things that I've learned over
the last couple of weeks to finish up my
PhD if you have any tips on how you are
finishing up your master pieas or your
PhD or another break project I would
love to know so put it in the comments
down below and otherwise see you next
week bye